what do you think of like um just kind
of like the influx in you know we lost
pnb rock out here
um which by the way after finding out
that it was like a father's father-son
yeah yeah that shit's crazy well that's
the moment of reflection I think
I think it's a moment to like like see
the layers behind the action itself
right like you got literally
a father and son Duo come in a crime
that cost the life of a successful young
man you feel I'm saying and um and from
what I heard I think the kid had an
ankle monitor on and he was yeah some
[ __ ] like that yeah but what I'm saying
is this like it's it's a like this is
what's happening bro and I see it a lot
in my in my in my community right like
there's men right now that are so caught
up with social media and this lifestyle
that it brings right
that they're trying to hang with the
kids
you know what I'm saying like there's no
there's no division in in clout is a
hell of a drug that's what I'm saying
right so we gotta we gotta look at
ourselves like
I I see it as a failure in the men you
know what I mean the men that are here
right now like ain't moving like men are
supposed to move we're not supposed to
be following the little homies or even
trying to be the little homies you know
I'm saying there's an art form to be in
a big homie yeah you know what I mean
like the art form is like you've been
through this [ __ ] so teach the little
homies better you feel what I'm saying
but right now you got a lot of grown men
trying to be little man youngsters you
feel what I mean big homies doing little
homie [ __ ] yeah so so but that's what
social media does bro like you
understand a lot of [ __ ] like
didn't even have names or reputations
before social media you know before you
really had to come outside like if
[ __ ] knew your dog you was
literally outside 24 7. yeah you never
went away and when you went to jail you
hit the block as soon as you got out and
you were hitting that [ __ ]
Street like there was no and when you
were in The Joint you were raising your
hand for every Mission like that's how
you that was social media before was
Stripes no I mean but now we're in this
virtual world dog where you know what I
mean you can make up your you know what
I'm saying and and a lot of men that
have
um what's the word I'm looking for that
have um confidence problems are looking
at that to validate who they are as men
you know saying you can't because social
media is mostly for children I think you
know I mean I think that only children
are allowed to live in their imagination
right I think that grown-ups live in
reality well they have to yeah right
because we we have obligations it feels
to pay man hell yeah you got buildings
to build you know we got to keep this
[ __ ] going you know what I'm saying like
so I think that um as a community that's
where we're at like not only a community
just in general bro because you see even
older women trying to act like they're
young like twerking again the bbls and
and like you know what I'm saying like
yeah it's well I see 40 year old women
talk about my N word this my n-word that
like girl like you you were just super
this [ __ ] for the last 30 years of
your life you know I mean like so we
have identity crisis going on right now
you know what I'm saying and I think
that um as man we got to act like it dog
because dog imagine that dog like
a father and son like shit's wife that's
like that that would be like [ __ ] I
couldn't even see myself telling my son
like Hey brother we're about to go rob
something drop old boy for all his
[ __ ] jewelry it's crazy and the fact
it was like I think that just reading
the details of like what actually
happened you're like damn that kid was
17 and decided to like consciously like
not just Rob him like Rob them and then
put him down well there's more layers
said think about that think about what
his dad is communicating to when they're
at home the example that his father's
giving him it's [ __ ] I ain't talking
about bodies around my little boy bro
what the [ __ ] like we talk sports if
anything and kid probably that kid
probably had a terrible life hell yeah
for sure if we check his record I'm sure
he's been out of jail you know custody
issues you know what I'm saying like all
that [ __ ] that comes with it so I mean
look bro I think that it's crazy that
let's say for instance it would have
been a cop killing a a young black man
or a Hispanic man right we're marching
right and we're doing all this [ __ ] and
we're there's awareness and we need to
be heard but when it's us failing us
nobody wants to talk about it right it's
almost like a hidden secret dirty secret
in the family you know we're not allowed
to talk about it why the [ __ ] not this
is when we really gotta address these
shits because at home is the root of all
the rest of the problems 100 in your
world so if we can stop that we can stop
a lot of other [ __ ] yeah but we don't
ever you know we're quick to point the
finger at everybody else yeah broken
homes man have a lot to do with them
yeah that's my you know I grew up in a
great family once my mom died from
cancer it was a wrap well you said that
you kind of grew up without a a
household yeah well I lost my mom when I
was 12 um 13 my mom died from um
pancreatic cancer my dad lost custody of
me like within six months of that I
became aware of the state at the age of
14. so you're just bouncing around yes
sir yeah damn yeah yeah so you know like
[ __ ] I mean
teach his own bro but you know I know I
know the reality of this [ __ ] that comes
with it you feel I'm saying and you know
I move like I move a certain way so but
I understand but I'm willing to the
consequence I'm going to deal with you
know what I'm saying and which ones I'm
not you know what I mean
you were talking uh we're talking a
little bit off camera just kind of about
like uh Mexicans and Hip-Hop yeah and uh
obviously there's I feel like um
the landscape of Mexican hip-hop isn't
the best place it's ever been yeah for
sure hell yeah um yeah because I've seen
both eras you know right I was like I
remember like when I first like
obviously growing up in Arizona we have
MC Magic we go to the low rider show it
was always at them off of Tucson yeah we
were doing all them shows [ __ ] high
power record yeah I was on stage with
them and uh and uh you know little Rob
and [ __ ] brown boy and all these guys
shout out a little Uno all these guys
and uh it was big over there it was huge
huge but it was like an extreme it was
it was literal Chicano rap hell yeah and
it was packed thousands of people
thousands hell yeah right and so like it
was like I always would like Little Rob
I think was probably one of the only
quote unquote Chicano rappers because I
don't consider MC Magic that because I
think he just makes love music that
[ __ ] love
um yeah he's he's auto-tune singer
before out of two singers were popular
right he's the voice box guy yeah after
Roger Troutman hey what up y'all it's
bootleg Kev here to stop the interview
sorry uh but we gotta pay the [ __ ]
bills and you know not only do we have
to pay the bills but we also gotta take
care of them [ __ ] out there that's
right make sure you go to bluetooth.com
right now you know the bootleg kept
podcast we are presented by bluetooth
proudly I happen to every once in a
while dabble in a little chooski you
know what I'm saying and let me tell you
something my dick thanks me for it every
single time uh so listen if you go to
Bluetooth use the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month's
supply for free now we're talking the
same active ingredient as Viagra as
Cialis without the awkward doctor's
appointment visit you just go online
they get you taken care of it gets
delivered right to your [ __ ] door in
discreet packaging it's a beautiful
thing and how about this
brand new product alert on Bluetooth all
right and I'm gonna [ __ ] this up for
sure so I'm gonna try to read it uh now
Bluetooth has a mint flavored chewable
with
bardenophil which is the same active
ingredient in Levitra and stackson
so shout out to Levitra
same active ingredient in the mint
flavor chewables so what are we doing go
get you a little mint boy go get you a
little blue chew whatever the [ __ ] you
need just know
whatever young lady or man or Etc that
you're dealing with they're gonna
[ __ ] thank you for it because your
dick's going to be harder than it's ever
been in your whole [ __ ] life man it's
gonna be great and like if you're a
single guy
take a blue chew
jack off
be a better jerk I'll tell you that all
right bluetooth.com go right now
and uh you know I know we have a lot of
male listeners who like underground rap
so chances are you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] but I promise you one thing you
take that blue too you're gonna beat
your dick like it stole something all
night long bluetooth.com use that promo
code bootleg right now and they will
give you the first month for free so go
do that [ __ ] um but little Rob had like
records that we played on the radio like
hits you know what I mean Around the
Clock yeah and so
um after him I felt like uh there was a
few records Big Gemini had a cool joint
um but I felt like there's kind of been
like once that era kind of dried out
it was kind of like dry I feel like
commercially for a lot of Mexican
hip-hop and now I mean look we talked
about King Lil G kind of held that flag
first a long time now there's so many
artists yes
um there's artists like a guy like cap G
yeah you know there's a guy who's from
Atlanta
um there's suede there's pesos
from Houston Man Gangnam like we're
killing it dog but what's always
happened with us is this bro like
we're misrepresented either in the
business side right or or were
misrepresented on the streets you know
what I'm saying and what I mean by like
the first era we're talking about Lil
Robin on them right it was exploited the
cholo whole look was exploited to you
couldn't [ __ ] even sell it no more
like Kosh was giving out deals to just
anybody you know what I mean so you
would go to that's where you got your
deal right yeah so you would go to
Target [ __ ] that was like 50 different
Mexican cholos on the shelves like you
didn't even know what to pick up and it
wasn't based on Talent they were just
giving deals on looks because they don't
they don't they didn't know how to
calibrate our talent right or what we
like you know what I'm saying
um
so then that happened the oversaturation
of the cholo cholo cholo to where it
ended up becoming almost like a mockery
you feel I'm saying it became it became
a joke you know what I'm saying um
because we evolved in the streets but as
far as like on the covers of CDs and
music we weren't right right because
they weren't letting no Talent new
talent in you feel insane because all
them cholos that they signed a lot of
them were hating on the rest you gotta
understand at that era we were still set
tripping on each other like crazy so
there was a lot of Street politics I
wasn't allow oh homie's dog but he from
18 we can't [ __ ] with him our homies
from White fans we can't [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying like there was a lot of
that going on
that's the biggest change that I noticed
this time I came home like the set
tripping amongst us in the business
wasn't as big but then what I saw was
this like
we had such a complex
from sounding like Chicano rappers that
at this point we became the exploiters
of the Black Culture by trying to sound
too black you feel what I'm saying so
it's like like Nipsey said in the album
you get abused long enough you become
the abuser we start abusing the game you
feel what I'm saying now
we're looking for an identity and yeah
there's a gang of homies with Talent
right coming up coming up coming up [ __ ]
shout out to burner too yeah I mean to
be honest burner's probably the most
yeah successful Mexican rappers yeah
yeah I mean [ __ ]
um so yeah so now you got at this point
right and the little homies
are being raised by IG right and what
does IG mainly put out there like the
Black Culture they're exploiting I just
exploring the [ __ ] of the Black Culture
to the fullest extent yeah without Black
Culture all these social media platforms
ain't [ __ ] would be you know I mean but
they're exploiting them in the wrong way
to me I think you know saying there is
no highlighting educated black man there
is no highlighting men black men that
race families that are pillars in their
Community you know I'm saying the ones
that do they're getting laid out every
single one is getting laid out you know
what I mean like smoke you know yeah the
[ __ ] that goes viral is always the [ __ ]
that's like okay we get it like some of
these Instagram Pages really just focus
on like
the drama the craziest [ __ ] dog and what
it and what they don't realize is that
social media is Raising this next
Generation right you feel I'm saying
literally their rate they're raising the
youth you know because they have more
influence from the phone than even their
own parents right you know what I'm
saying
um so now that's where we're at and I
was just having this conversation
earlier with drummer boy shout out
drummer boy he's another one you know
like a Forefront of this [ __ ] he's from
uh Pomona yeah yeah so the homie's
telling me like he literally asked me
the same [ __ ] but a different context
he's like how do you feel about where
we're at right now and I'm like dog like
right now we gotta fight for identity as
a culture because if we don't
what's going to happen is we're going to
be coming to Houston
and and I don't mean that and no
disrespectful way but the Hispanics in
Houston
have adapted the Black Culture
completely to where you can't really
tell the difference between
a Mexican rapper and a black rapper do
you think it's
a subject matter thing I know I just
think that I just think that
man you don't really want to know what I
think dog cause it's gonna sound ugly
yeah but I think it comes with a type of
submission bro you know what I'm saying
like they gave up on trying to represent
the culture in its purest form you know
what I mean so they just kind of like
you know what this is how we gonna get
on
like I could I could I could easily say
the n-word in every song right now right
and I'll probably do better numbers
I could probably go braids my dog and
start doing you know what I'm saying
like
because that's where we're at right now
you know I'm saying everybody imitating
the Black Culture right without no
regard for their culture no regard for
their lineage no regard for their blood
and no regard for their history yeah I
think like it also depends on where you
were raised because I look at a guy like
that's [ __ ] no no no but listen but
listen now I was gonna say I look at a
guy like Captain in certain I look like
a guy like cap G who's never I've never
heard him say the N word yeah when you
listen to cap G he was raised in Atlanta
right yeah so like a lot of his music
sounds like Atlanta you know what I'm
saying but then he'll have other records
that have a lot of heavy like he has a
day without a Mexican which was a
[ __ ] Banger so I think cap G has done
a really good job of like balancing them
I'm a dude who grew up where I grew up
I'm from Atlanta which is like yeah in
my opinion the capital of like hip-hop
culture now you know yeah most
definitely yeah I think cap G has done a
great job of life so then why don't we
see a lot more blacks trying to be
Mexican that grew up that grew up around
Mexicans
I don't I mean [ __ ] okay that's the
proof in the pudding to me you feel what
I'm saying it's like what's the biggest
form of humility
imitation yeah okay then you feel what
I'm saying and I'm not I mean and hey
well listen listen talk to me let's go
there have been a lot of artists I hate
to beat the tiger horse dead yeah but
listen but they but they the way they do
it is very strategically Smart Bro and
then I know YG just put a record out
with Cuco yeah yeah so like I think that
there has been and I think that like
but it's a small [ __ ] number true but
those guys grew up in La yeah YG signed
uh Savoy Loco you know why do dresses
like us for the most part he's got the
Stacy Adams he's got the last of his
head his whole [ __ ] everything like the
homies I think I think YG has been
somebody who obviously grew up around
Mexicans and in my opinion at least yeah
has paid homage Tastefully hell yeah I
think look honestly for whatever people
say about YG or how they say it like I
think that he comes off sincere when he
feels like he has sincere love that's
what I'm saying like of course I grew up
in Tiger [ __ ] I'm sorry that didn't come
off sincere at all you know I mean that
was like it was and listen all much love
to that and that [ __ ] is old as [ __ ]
yeah he took the video down yeah it's
great like all up to him ain't no
getting off the table you know cool but
it did it didn't come up it came off it
didn't come off whoever was behind him
right failed right right you know what
I'm saying but you know like I'm that's
just the way I see it you know what I'm
saying like that's the way I see it and
um it's about to do another shift like
it's about to do another shift like if
you hit the block right now there's no
more skinny jeans duh the little homies
are dressing like me now again right
yt's and 501s all day I think well I
think two the other thing we got to talk
about is like obviously hip-hop is Black
Culture first most definitely so I think
well I would say that it's white and
black culture I think it's black and I I
know a lot of people and Puerto Rico
it's black no I'm gonna tell you why I
say that though why do you say why
Beastie Boys is [ __ ] you mean one of the
first hip-hop groups ever yeah but the
first no you're right you're right
you're right you're right but that was
like 84. I understand it wasn't like at
the roots but I'm saying when it
mattered
come on it was a bunch of white boys
from right here I think I think it's
you know if we go back to like you know
79.81 it's Puerto Ricans and blacks yeah
you know what I mean for sure over there
yeah the mecca right like right hell
yeah most definitely but
when it took the stage and it was really
time to make it a business
it was the Beastie Boys and it was all
Cool J Beastie Boys Grand Master Flash
right now see what I'm saying so you
know I mean
that's not how I feel I'm just going by
what I saw growing up because I'm a huge
hip-hop fan you know what I'm saying but
um but there's beef over that too like
people wait man who gives a [ __ ] dog I
believe like look dog
how do you create something there's the
people that build it and there's the
people that fund the building we funded
the building so how are we not a part of
it if we didn't believe in it and push
hip-hop the creation of it and stand
behind it it would have never took off
the way it did I mean and I mean all of
us I think but I think like the answer
to what you were asking like why don't
people imitating what we're doing I
think if you like one black culture is
the number one most influential culture
in in the US yeah yeah and you could say
it has been Asia everywhere in the world
hell yeah and Hip-Hop culture hip hop is
the number one genre of music in the
world that's that's a fact a fact so
hip-hop's the number one genre of music
and it's it's it's derived from Black
Culture it is it is Black Culture you
know what I'm saying so I think that
that and black culture is the most
influential culture in the country
period like that's no debate yeah no
debate yeah like fashion you go to h m
you go that's all right yeah 100 so I
think that that's probably a little bit
more closer to like why you were it's
like yeah well why is nobody imitating
what we're doing and I do think that
obviously like there's very small
examples where people okay homage to
them I hear that part of the argument
and I've thought about that part of the
argument okay but then when I see rap
videos
low riders and well especially on the
west coast you know so I was gonna say
would you consider I mean because to me
no writing is us that's us 100 oh yeah
but you think about you know Dr Dre
Snoop Dogg oh hell yeah they adopted him
100 yeah but they did it right though
we didn't say that they did it in a way
that they paid homage hell yeah they did
a cloud they did it with class yeah you
know what I'm saying they they
represented they they they because
really low riders is is is is obviously
a Mexican thing but it's a la thing it's
La thing yeah yeah start on the east
side yeah yeah but um I think that the
way they did it was um they showed like
the the the the parts they should
highlight like the dope [ __ ] that we do
you know what I'm saying nah you know
goofy [ __ ] you know what I'm saying or
[ __ ] dressed like Mariachis
like we don't we're not out here
dressing like we're at you know what I'm
saying like I mean let's just be real
you feel I'm saying I get it's a part of
the culture huge part of culture but I
never seen one of my homies on the Block
dress like a mariachi Mariachi say it
right like I'm talking like you know I
mean like I don't know no better but you
know what I'm saying so I mean I don't
know I'm I'm just a person that goes by
facts and I like I like honesty so I'm
saying so if I'm gonna be honest like I
see a lot of [ __ ] that um that isn't
necessarily fair but it is what it is
dog like at this point
um you know we're either gonna where
they're gonna rise from this with our
own Foundation our own structure or
we're just gonna become a part of the
rest of the machine you know what I'm
saying so it's on us I think at that
part and that's what I was talking to
Drummer Boy about like I told him like
look bro like this is your time
like what you guys do at this moment is
going to Define
our people in the game for a while you
know I mean because right now like as a
people in this music game we're
searching for an identity you know what
I'm saying we really are like I was
talking to him earlier about the way
that he creates music you know and I was
telling him the same [ __ ] like bro if
you look different and you're a
different ethnicity you should be
through the roof right now bro yeah but
you got to fight the stigma you know
what I'm saying so do you fight the
stigma do you because hip-hop don't love
us for whatever it's worth we love
hip-hop but hip-hop don't love us at all
you know what I'm saying so are you
gonna stay in a toxic relationship or
are you gonna move on and find a new
Breezy and make your family you know you
know what I really think it is man I
think
there has to be an honest conversation
where we're like who's the who's the
Mexican rapper that you feel like
was on the same level as Drake or Jay-Z
or there hasn't been one ever so that's
what I'm saying yeah it's gonna take
that guy but why though hasn't there
been one I mean it's gonna take that guy
in the past yeah where you're like
there's somebody that's so dope it's
undeniable yeah so to me it's like
there's been a lot of cool like cool
dope Mexican artists but has there been
one that's so crazy that that it's just
undeniable whether it's
ability look at the one that they hit
records the one that they did blow up
huh no Talent on I mean six nine bro the
one that they did blow up like come on
bro like okay okay so so and I don't
want to get into the decision thing
because that's been yeah that's besides
six nine yeah had records
he had undeniable records okay so it
didn't matter if he was like very
deniable how come La wasn't jamming them
all crazy in the clubs they were the
clubs isn't the streets though bro yeah
the club is one stream I'm talking about
I'm talking about 2018
dropped who wasn't playing that [ __ ] on
the Block everybody okay then let's go
more relevant when um YG Drop My Crazy
Life who in the [ __ ] wasn't playing that
[ __ ] out here everybody everybody
everybody that's everywhere because I
travel everywhere people are playing all
right six nine wasn't booming like that
I don't know man I think a lot of those
numbers see to me the six nine [ __ ] was
to me a perfect example of somebody who
just made records that like were kind of
undeniable so it didn't really matter
that he was a clown and this is before
he snitched yeah of course yeah when
issue was moving and we had that
conversation where I was like
artists gotta like
happen to be Mexican but be dope first
yeah and I think six nine by consequence
six nine yeah people were like oh he's
got some gummo and all that [ __ ] was for
them shits were hard the Nikki record
was hard and he happened to be a Mexican
guy yeah does that make sense yeah it
does yeah it does so I think like he had
records but was he but was he I think he
had no but was he representing the
culture
I think he was representing his culture
how he grew up maybe does that make
sense I don't know yeah I could be I
don't know yeah you know what I'm saying
but
[ __ ] I think that I think I think that
though but that's an example of what I
was saying like yeah Who's the artist
that like is making undeniable hit
records or is just so crazy that it's
like yo this [ __ ] King Lil G
broke through right right and he's
selling out shows all over the nation
yeah he was on [ __ ] why the [ __ ] was
there no love because he represented me
and how I look that's fair you
understand what I'm saying like the
homie look at stole the product that
girl you know the product she does shows
everywhere does it she's still not sure
she just got nominated for a Latin
Grammy well thank God for her God hey
and snow is the you know she's a god
level MC for sure okay so that's what
I'm saying like why why why I don't know
no the little girl Munch just took off
[ __ ] I don't know where one Snow's
never had one of those records though
what the [ __ ] and everybody's flying
around no I'm just speaking facts you
know I mean can Munch this much that and
this [ __ ] [ __ ] like the track isn't
that hard I mean it's cool but you know
it's a Tick-Tock thing yeah but you guys
know the products slaughtering [ __ ] like
I mean [ __ ] come on bro like this snow
is slaughtering [ __ ] in her world in the
same way that like
think of tech Nine tech nine can wrap
his [ __ ] ass off I think she's more
dimensional than him oh of course
because she's she's I heard
um that's not a direct like correlation
to their followings or their music I see
what you're saying you know what I'm
saying so I just think that like yeah
man I think I think that with everything
we've talked about what we can both
agree on is that it's all going in a
positive direction well yeah any any any
[ __ ] momentum is good I mean look
money sign swage has a deal with
Atlantic Records oh yeah I mean cat G
was on Atlantic he's about to drop a
record with Jay Balvin you know you got
homies like me running around tearing
[ __ ] up man apparently 100 on their own
I'm doing features [ __ ] I
shouldn't be doing them but I couldn't
do them 15 years ago [ __ ] just
and you say you're you got a project on
the way with Benny The Butcher yeah we
gotta stop the interview tell you about
our partners at Odd Socks well first of
all let's check out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
all together bootleg Kev and you will
save 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course we're presented by
Odd Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
yeah well Benny's a friend of the family
you know so yeah I got some coming with
the boy in the future
um I just dropped my album Hunger Games
two I got prayers you got prayers on the
shouts and prayers shots of prayers
prayers sells out wherever he goes into
penalty too yeah he's firing you know
but he don't rap but no he's fine either
way though he's doing it yeah he's still
married to Kat Von D yeah hell yeah he
ain't letting her go yeah he ain't
letting that go hell no he got like the
the if it was a Selena Kat Von D's
probably next right I mean I would think
like the sweethearts of our community
you know yeah how like when you work
with someone like prayers who obviously
maybe uh sonically is a little bit but
he's a southsider like me right so we
Bond on that level you know what I'm
saying and
um and you know like there's something
to be said about our Brotherhood you
know what I'm saying like that South
Side Brotherhood is very um it's very um
how can you say it man like it's
automatic love bro you know yeah so we
gel We Vibe and it was It was a yeah it
was like a puzzle to put together you
know what I'm saying even the production
was was very hard to find but we did it
you know what I mean and I think it was
dope you know I'm saying like to bring
two worlds together that
that represent art you know what I'm
saying like we're not on some ignorant
just you know I mean making noise we
really try to make records you feel I'm
saying that's important yeah I think
that's important you gotta make records
man it's important so so yeah we just
did that um should we move it out here
you know what I mean we we um as far as
myself personally I just concentrate on
on making timeless music dawg like I'm
not here to follow Trends it's important
I'm not here to like um [ __ ] appease
anybody you know what I'm saying like
I'm just trying to follow my heart my
soul and and thus far [ __ ]
it's led me to all the right look I'm
here with you yeah you know so I met you
were backstage with Benny in them yeah
you were shroom the [ __ ] out always
you feel me look who's back there
Freeway Rick was back there the real
freeway rig who else is back the
legendary people like Yeah The Crooked
Eye Alchemist like think about these are
all people that I grew up like [ __ ] I
met Jay-Z I met Jay-Z where'd you meet
Jay-Z I mean Jay-Z you were there too
food but um I didn't say what's up to
you where at
um was this no I didn't because there's
so many people there first one is all
the show we went to the novel we were
all there
shout out to Jay-Z though I'm not saying
this too right you know but me and the
homie right we're in the hallway we're
the two only two essays in the hallway
in the green you know how the noble
setup yeah
so I'm a huge Jay-Z fan of course like
one of the only this will tell you one
of the only albums I had on the yard was
like Reasonable Doubt I had Reasonable
Doubt I had graduation and then I had um
mob deep
um Murder music you know fire classics
classics right
so those are the three albums that I'm
doing time with right so um [ __ ] like I
said okay so I'm I'm in I'm waiting for
Benny because I know how the shows end I
wanted to get to the back yeah you know
what it is yeah yeah before everybody's
all the rush comes in so I see um G pre
goes homeboy with him his older homie I
forgot his name but his OG homie I
recognize him first and then I that's
when Jake I had the dreads you know the
big thing so right away I was like oh
[ __ ] that's that's Jay-Z and the homie's
like no it's not I'm like food trust me
that's hopeful like you know so he walks
by and sure enough we see him but I
didn't want to you know hey what you
know what I'm saying like I don't know
I'd rather just admire her boy from the
distance you know and and enjoy the
moment
so he goes over there and then on the
way back Giga comes out by himself
literally you know and I'm tripping like
damn no security with a little boy like
what the [ __ ] and it's just me and the
homie stand in the corner and I'm
dressed almost like when I'm dressed
right now I got my gold on the homie got
way more [ __ ] than me but we're both
bald and we're chilling and Jay-Z walks
up to me right and he's like what's up
brother and I'm like what's up you know
I mean I didn't even know how to act to
be honest with you know worse so I shake
his hand we exchange a few words polili
and then he leaves and then I pull out
my phone I take a picture from behind
around like oh no I would have got to
pick but I wanted to bro but I was
wondering
all my cool points can get thrown right
out the window like yo Jay look man yeah
I gotta get this so when he walks away
the I swear to y'all know why but the
first that comes to my mind I was like
damn I bet you I bet you Jay-Z thought
we were the plug
there's no way he thought I wrapped her
[ __ ] new rap you know what I'm saying
like I know for a fact this [ __ ]
thought we were we were the plug you
know what I'm saying but either way
though it was dope you feel the same but
um but yeah all that [ __ ] you know it's
all due to diligence and like hard work
and carrying yourself the right way you
know what I'm saying like I know a lot
of people highlight ignorance right now
but dog let me tell you like on the
Block what's gonna make you survive and
make you thrive is your intelligence you
know what I'm saying at the end of the
day like knowing how to move knowing
where to be at knowing how to conduct
yourself like all that loud mouth [ __ ]
is only good on the phone dog yeah when
it comes to real real business nobody
wants to sit
across the table from somebody that's a
that's a liability right you feel I'm
saying and somebody that don't know
about investing somebody that doesn't
believe in the worth of where they're at
and what they're doing at the moment
like I know the words because Doug in
the blink of an eye I could go back to
the cell I remember that [ __ ] vividly
you know what I'm saying right now what
time is it it's two o'clock right now
I'd be watching on the People's Court
I'd be watching The People's Court I'd
be getting ready to go out to yard right
two o'clock yard right man the first
unlock two o'clock we'd be ready I'd
have I'd be on the toilet no lie three
yard waiting for my door to unlock while
my celly is on the bunk looking like a
Raging Bull ready to come out to yard
because we're that excited to come out
for a few [ __ ] hours so crazy you
know what I'm saying I want to shout out
to a couple of artists we're talking
about dope rappers coyotes dope those
those dudes are incredible and a dough
man from uh Houston Houston yeah he can
rap his ass off yeah I had a little I
had I had a communication with the
coyotes you know when they um
well I'm sure they still signed a whack
but you know I just reached out to them
you know what I'm saying and um
told them like man dog like there's
better ways to go about this [ __ ] I
would say that just because someone
signed to somebody doesn't necessarily
mean that they you know I feel you say
that too but um
I mean to this point unfortunately their
Mexican artist signed a wax so yeah
exactly yeah yeah so you know but but
they're doing their thing [ __ ] you know
and you know it's all love you know what
I'm saying at the end of the day well
there it is man well look uh your album
is out hell yeah Hunger Games two the
price of integrity
bangers all the way through you a PC
you're a [ __ ] don't listen to my [ __ ]
you ain't gonna like it though I
guarantee
that night don't listen to my [ __ ] yeah
um you don't hustle you don't stand on
your word don't listen to my [ __ ] like
you ain't gonna like it you know there
it is facts appreciate you pulling up
and you picking this [ __ ] boom
appreciate it yes sir